[Music]
zootopia AKA zootropolis hit theaters in
2016 and beat just about every record
there was to break at the time even
today the movie is still one of the most
popular Disney films rightly so we
believe as utopia has succeeded in
becoming a film that is truly for
everyone with an exciting story and
enough grown-up humor there has been
speculation for a long time whether and
when a second part will be released
however things have gone quiet on this
topic so we want to look back on it for
you with the release of the zootopia
plus series on Disney plus we want to
deal with the subject of how realistic
zootopia 2 is and most importantly what
the story could look like before we get
into that let's recap part one around
Judy Hopps and Nicholas pibarius Nick
Wilde thus for those who have not seen
it you might want to skip ahead quickly
or even better access your Disney Plus
subscription and watch the movie now
Judy Hopps is a bunny with great
Ambitions as she dreams of becoming a
policewoman and so after graduating from
high school she sets off on her journey
from bunny Borough to zootopia where she
joins utopia's Police Department quickly
she realizes that she is not accepted as
a woman cough by the others as a
superior meter maid she has to fight her
way up the hierarchy when she meets Nick
the fox the latter tricks her causing
her only to become angrier on the verge
of quitting Mrs otterton seeks her help
her husband is missing and although
Chief BOGO is not pleased Judy has her
first case along with Nick she sets out
to find Mr otterton and it soon becomes
clear that there is more behind it they
discover that many animals are missing
all of them predators and most
importantly that they have gone berserk
or rather extremely aggressive during
their investigations they find out that
mayor leodor Lionheart has had the
animals trapped and imprisoned but
merely to find out what is wrong with
them as he claims nonetheless he has to
vacate his post and the second mayor
Dawn Bellwether the Sheep assumes the
position on his behalf now the Ambiance
turns towards the predators in town and
the animals have to deal with fear
however Judy and Nick find out that
Bellwether is to blame for everything as
she holds a grudge against the
carnivores and thus intended to get rid
of them together they managed to foil
her plan and Nick ends up joining the
zdp himself
unfortunately we don't know anything
about the exact plot yet but there are
some rumors floating around about the
second part of zootopia and also the
online community has some ideas besides
it can be said that the social topics
addressed in the first part alone can be
further expanded in an interview with
Cinema Blend Nick's voice actor Jason
Bateman already revealed that the two of
them will tidy up the streets as
partners there are some new cops out
there he added so bad guys be warned
thus it is evident who will be in the
thick of the action once again Judy and
Nick
we also hope that the two partners will
finally make it to the areas of zootopia
that haven't been shown yet although we
are told that the beginning of the film
that zootopia is a huge City we only get
to see downtown rainforest district and
Tundra town in the course of the first
movie yet there are many more urban
areas to explore like the canal District
canyonland marshlands Meadowlands polar
Street and Sahara Square however the
capital city is not the one that should
be of interest for the upcoming
storyline we actually do not know
anything yet about the planet or the
continent in which the movie takes place
sure there were a couple of scenes in
bunny Brew but that's it there is still
an entire world to discover besides so
far only mammals have been featured in
part one what about other species like
fish reptiles and insects in case these
creatures really exist the second film
could deal with the question of why they
were excluded from zootopia and
re-examine the topic of xenophobia
but not only as official Partners at the
zdp as there seems to be something else
going on between the two of them after
all the first part ends with Nick
claiming that Judy knows she has a crush
on it which she confirms so pretty much
everyone agrees that there'll be some
kind of Love Story developing around the
two of them who knows this might even be
something special in zootopia so far we
know that only animals of the same breed
have ever become a couple and here we
are actually talking about two hostile
species nowadays this would of course
strike a chord again if the movie
addressed topics such as free love and
different sexualities in general they
can pick up the topic of gender one more
time and explore it in more depth Judy
is the only bunny working for the police
and besides officer Francine the
elephant she is also the only female who
seems to be working for the authorities
in general most of the animals we
encounter are male besides her and
Francine we only see the star singer
gazelle the concerned Mrs otterton Mafia
heiress frufrou and Dawn Bellwether this
could be a neat transition to sexism in
society
we are informed in the first movie that
little mammals cannot join the zootopia
police department due to their size and
power that was all history because Judy
does join the zdp however there is a far
more Sinister influence at work it is
believed that the vole Mafia dominates
the police force the idea supports this
allegation by claiming the strong
criminal gang penetrated the zdp's
higher-ups and pushed them to Outlaw
pint-sized officers as a result there is
no agency small enough just to police
the voles allowing their illegal
operation to continue for the
foreseeable future though this
relationship may be altering now that
Judy has encountered Mr big but if
proven correct this can bring a
significant amount of attention to the
sequel this Theory would revolve around
exploring the illegal operations being
carried in the dark in zootopia the vole
politics and the expertise of Judy and
Nick in capturing the mafia people who
does not absolutely love a crime Mafia
situation
a somewhat sensitive topic could be that
of class Society at first glance
everything in zootopia seems to look
like love peace and Harmony yet just by
looking at Nick and his accomplished the
beginning of the film it seems that
there are animals who have to earn their
money in a shady way in the city of
endless opportunities and so there is
for instance also a mafia in zootopia a
story about this would be particularly
suitable for Nick in his old life after
all until he met Judy he was not really
doing any honest work you say the gap
between rich and poor might be too
severe for an animated film well then
don't forget one of the core messages of
the first film in an amusing way it
shows how racism is a fear that is
promoted by those in power therefore the
next part could well try its luck with
other serious topics
what most of you probably do not know is
that zootopia was originally intended to
be a spy movie where a spy arrives on a
mysterious island in a world full of
mammals perhaps it could be a storyline
for the sequel and why not it's not cast
in stone that Nick and Judy have to stay
with the zdp forever especially Nick
could be well pictured in the role of a
secret agent the second part could
easily revert from a buddy cop comedy to
the original envisioned spy genre
okay this theory is too dark for a
Disney movie but still very interesting
so we wanted to share with you the
elegance and peace and Tranquility of
zootopia is that prey and Predator
coexist peacefully with the former never
having to fear being killed and eaten by
the latter unfortunately this
Arrangement may have catastrophically
unintended consequences in this case
this idea concentrates on a serious
population problem or a horrifying
government-run breeding program in
zootopia Judy Hopps confronts her folks
about possessing 275 siblings which is a
big number many of these innocent
brother and sister bunnies would
undoubtedly perish if Predators could
continue to pursue prey but in zootopia
they will live a peaceful life yet
unknowingly culminating in massive
overcrowding in food shortage the one
and only method for avoiding this is for
the administration to exert control over
its citizens without becoming too
gruesome this Theory entails a large
number of animals getting transferred to
a ranch to be sacrificed fans will be
riveted to their screens if the movie
concentrates on this frightening idea
but at this same time this idea will
capture how peaceful and all-inclusive
place like zootopia can have dark
secrets and dirty Politics as well just
like the real world
so now we have heard a few possibilities
of how the plot could go on but what
does the fan community on Reddit
actually say there one theory is Prevail
namely that we will meet Dick's father
in the course of the film and the latter
will be arrested by Judy when the
interrogation reveals who it is Nick
Falls back into his old Behavior
patterns the rest of the movie will then
delve into Nick and his father's past
and find answers as to why he abandoned
him before he was even born in general
fans on Reddit are crying out to know
more about the Sly Fox
but when is zootopia 2 coming opinions
differ on this because Disney is not
even officially confirmed a second part
some years ago they probably would not
have even thought of making a sequel but
since Wreck-It Ralph and Frozen they're
considering a theatrical sequel looking
at the numbers this would only be
natural as utopia was one of the most
successful movies from the Disney
Animation Studios in the last 10 years
anyways with the recent schedule updates
from Disney's animation slate it is safe
to say that zootopia 2 will not be
hitting theaters before the end of 2024
as soon as we know more you will of
course be notified in our weekly news
well here we go those were all the
theories about the second part of
zootopia which idea do you think is the
best so far and do you have any other
suggestions on how it could continue let
us know in the comments if you enjoyed
this video feel free to give us a thumbs
up if you don't want to miss any more of
our videos you might want to subscribe
to us see you next time
[Music]
foreign